The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT Open CourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So this
is the great groups class.
Let me do a quick
background here to get us up
to where we are at the moment.
And then, I'll just do a quick
overview of the William Rosen
book on the
Industrial Revolution.
And I'll do just a summary the
Bennis and Biederman rules.
And then it's your class.
So, quick background, you
remember these characters Solo,
Robert Solo, and Paul Romer,
and we'll just do a quick recap.
But Solo, essentially, taught us
that technological and related
innovation is the dominant
causative factor of growth.
Romer taught us that
behind that, in effect,
R&D system is what he
calls human capital engaged
in research.
In other words, it's the talent
base that's in that system,
that these are to direct
innovation factors.
And then, there's a whole
set in this complex ecosystem
of innovation.
There's a whole set of
direct and indirect factors.
So, Solo and Romer,
we just talked about,
then innovation occurs in
a complex kind of ecosystem
of different factors.
Some are direct, like talent and
R&D. Some are much less direct.
Some are set by
the private sector.
Some are set by government.
And you can see
here that rich list
of kind of factors
that aren't as central,
that aren't as critical, but
still must be accounted for.
In looking at that system, they
do play within that innovation
system.
And then, a third
question, which
has been at the heart
of a lot of what we've
been talking about in class, is
there a third direct innovation
factor?
And arguably, the organization
of science and technology
is that factor.
So, we talked about how the
US innovation system evolved
and kind of told the
story of its evolution
in that World War II time table.
The Rad Lab at MIT was an
important foundational moment.
Vannevar Bush was the author
of that kind of leading tract
on what the US
post-war innovation
system was going to look like.
And his model led
to the creation in--
and the continuation, really
starting in World War II,
it started in World War II, of
the federally funded research
university, and then the
plethora of basic science
research agencies in the US.
So, that's innovation on
the institutional level.
But, as we've talked about
before people innovate, not
institutions, which is really
the topic of today's class.
And we're going to run through
a series of great innovation
groups.
We'll run through five of them.
So, we'll lay out Edison
and Bardeen, Oppenheimer,
the Xerox PARC group, Boyer
and Swanson, and Craig Venter.
So, we'll do a group of
three that sort of came out
of the earlier physical
sciences side into the IT side,
and then we'll do two life
science leaders and groups.
Just as background,
William Rosen
wrote this book called
The Industrial Revolution
in Britain, and he has
important lessons for us
on the process of innovation,
and I'll just recap.
I'll just pull out of that book
some thoughts that may help us
think a little bit in the
big picture kind of way
about some of these issues.
First, he identifies something
called the intelligent hand.
And that concept is
taken from Charles Bell,
but it really originates
in Immanuel Kant
who identified the hand
as a window in the world.
And since MIT's model is mind
and hand, in other words,
in many ways, it's
learning by doing,
that's an important
conceptual framework
when we begin to think about
innovation that's clearly not
mind only.
It is clearly mind and hand.
It's the combination
of the ability
to do things physically
and in a tactile way,
carry them out as well as
think those great conceptual
organizing thoughts.
Davinci combines,
and I've just been
reading a biography
of him, but he
amazingly in his thousands
of pages of notebooks
combines his incredible
ability to do art and draw
with his highly inventive
skill set of imagining
all kinds of new
machines, right,
that were unimagined in
the context of the 1500's
when he's writing.
Helicopters, as one example.
His ability to see and
conceptually see and draw
helps enable him to invent
these big conceptual ideas.
So that's another way of
looking at mind and hand.
Right.
Another way of looking
at the intelligent hand.
So Rosen argues that the
visual, and the tactile,
and the mind, and the
eye, and the hand,
are all critical in this
innovation invention process.
Just to quote-- to take a few
moments here and pull moments
out of his book,
one is what he calls
the flash of insight problem.
And the example he
provides is James Watt
is walking on the
green of Glasgow.
And in that moment,
and, of course,
it's Scotland, so he's
walking past the golf shack.
Right.
Where else?
He has the idea for
condensation in achieving
a much higher level of
efficiency of steam power.
So, there are steam engines
working in mines prior to Watt,
but it's that walk on
the green where he writes
that the inside came together.
But, we have to put
this into the context.
His insight, as he's walking
next to the golf shack,
appears effortless,
but it's built
on a long term project
of understanding
how steam power worked.
And Watt is an
interesting figure
because he comes out of a
poor background in Scotland.
He gets-- he's a
skilled artisan.
He becomes an instrument maker.
So, he's working on early
scientific, and navigational,
and astronomy instruments.
And he works in London,
and he's exposed
to the finest skilled
artisans working
on those early
scientific instruments.
He comes back to Glasgow.
He's blocked by the local
Guild from setting up
his own instrument shop.
What's he going to do?
He takes a job at the
University of Edinburgh
and actually becomes
quite a close friend
of Adam Smith who's inventing
economics at the same time.
And he digs into, in
depth, into steam engines,
and begins to develop
concepts of how they actually
function and work.
I mean, this is
pre-thermodynamics.
But Watt is developing a
lot of those early idea
concepts that will lead to that
conceptual kind of framework.
And he spends 10
years on that project
before he has the
walk on the green.
Right.
Doing these various projects.
So it's that 10 years
that enables the insight.
So, Anders Ericsson who
Rosen also writes about
develops the expert
performance model.
Its time on task.
It's not talent alone.
So, it's really important
to do those 10,000
hours of practicing
before you can pretend
to be a serious musician.
Right.
So, you may appear
musically fluent,
but those 10,000
hours of practice
turn out to be absolutely
critical foundations.
So, it's this combination
of expert performance,
Anders Ericsson
Ericsson would argue,
with that intellectual
capability
that's very key here.
Michael Polanyi, a
philosopher and psychologist
thinks about learning by doing.
What does that
process look like?
And he develops a whole
concept of tactile knowing,
that it's a combination
of knowledge and skills,
actual physical tactile
kinds of skills.
Eric Kandel begins the work
in neuroscience and beginning
to tell us how
learning can occur.
And he's there great Columbia
neuroscientist Nobel winner.
He tells us how
the brain chemistry
changes in the course of
actual tactile experience.
Right.
Which helps us
understand why that--
its mind and hand
in combination.
So, let me let me
leave those there.
And then, turn to Warren
Bennis and Patricia Ward
Biederman who wrote this book
called Organizing Genius back
in 1997.
So Bennis had been an
MIT faculty member.
He became president of
a university in Ohio.
He then moved to
teach business at USC,
which is where he's writing this
book from along with Patricia
Biderman from USC.
And they, after watching closely
a lot of innovation groups,
as you all saw, they
develop the idea
that these groups seem to
operate on rule systems.
That there are kind of
rules to govern a group.
And that these different
innovation groups
share a lot of rules.
So, that's the key
concept here that we're
going to be playing when we
discuss our great groups here
in class.
And they run through--
I'll just run through
some of the basic rules
that you all, you know,
by now are familiar with,
but they argue that greatness
starts with superb people.
And they quote Bob
Taylor of Xerox PARC,
you can't pile together
enough good people
to make a great one.
That great groups and great
leaders both need each other,
and create each other,
and enable each other,
that it's not leadership
alone, it's the group
and the group needs leadership.
But the leadership have
got to be able to play off
of and interact with a group.
And we'll see different
leadership styles
in putting these
great groups together
as we talk about
these groups today.
Great group leaders love
talent and know how to find it.
Right.
That's to create
a great group you
got have great talent in it.
And a role of the great group
leader is to find that talent.
The talent in great
groups can work together.
And in the Oppenheimer
story, Beth,
you're going to tell us some
of the dissonance points
I'm sure in that great group.
And certainly-- and Martin
and the Bardeen, Brattain,
and Shockley story,
you're going to tell us
about some of the dissidents
in that great group
that kind of blew it up.
Great groups like to think
they're on a mission from God.
In other words,
they have to believe
that this is the most
important mission that
could ever possibly happen.
Otherwise, they
never get anywhere.
So they have enormous zeal.
Right.
And it's almost a
kind of religious zeal
as they embark on
their projects.
They wear blinders.
In other words, they can
focus only on their project.
They can stay on task And
make that their entire focus.
Otherwise, again,
would they get there?
They are optimistic.
They are not realistic.
So, if they were realistic
about what they were attempting,
they would never try it.
But, because they
are optimists, they
have the willingness to
persevere in the expectation
that something is
going to happen.
Great groups are islands,
but they have a bridge
to the mainland.
So, Luyao, when she tells us
about the Xerox PARC story,
is going to tell us the
classic island bridge story.
But typically, great
groups need to get put
on an island, a
protected island,
out of the control
of bureaucracies,
of the suits, where
they can do their
own thing, where
they can come up
with their inventions
and then innovations.
But, nothing happens
to those innovations
unless they have a bridge
back to decision makers
that enable those technologies
to get effectuated,
to be put into place.
Great groups have an enemy.
Probably the most
famous in your time,
maybe you're all
too young for this,
remember those big blue
commercials that Steve Jobs ran
during super bowls?
You know attacking IBM and its
minions who were wearing suits
in this kind of dark
Orwellian advertisement
talking about Apple
is up against this,
you know, authoritarian
IBM enemy.
Right.
It was a shocking
ad at the time.
But it gives you a
very good example
of just how it felt to
be at Apple pushing up
against IBM's PC trying to
get your Mac out the door.
Great groups have the right
person in the right job.
They have to avoid what we could
call Hollywood syndrome, right,
where everybody is a star.
They've got to find ways by
which everybody contributes,
and has a critical area
that they can handle.
The groups give their talent
whatever they need to thrive,
and they free them
from anything else.
The group needs protection
from the outside forces.
Typically these groups
are very high morale.
They're having a wonderful time.
They're having the
time of their lives.
It is , funny and
exciting, and it's 24/7,
but they're having the
times of the lives.
And when they write later
about what it was like,
these are high points
in their lives.
Tyranny destroys
the collaboration.
So, in a way, they've
got to be, and we'll
see different leadership
styles because it's by no means
always democratic, but
there's got to be an ability
to pitch in and contribute.
Yeah, Max?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
was just going to ask
how does Apple fit in there?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Yeah, well, it's
going to be a very
interesting set of questions.
MARTIN: Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
And maybe we'll
raise that when we think about
how Thomas Edison operates
as a leader in that kind
of 19th century leadership
context, which is
different than our era.
Teams are collaborative.
They need to be flat and
non-hierarchical, and pretty
democratic.
A lot of these rules we
start to see in the Rad Lab,
this is kind of how
the Rad Lab functions
in developing the first
federally funded research
and development center,
creating the model for that.
The Rad Lab follows
a lot of these rules.
They use the challenge
mission, challenge model.
In other words,
they've got to be
solving a really big problem.
This is not curiosity
driven research.
This is problem solving.
It's solving a challenge.
You have to ship.
In other words,
there comes a time
when you have to get
something out of the door.
You've got to be able
to set a time frame
and move out your technology
within a plausible time period
to actually get into a market.
Xerox PARC has a lot of
trouble with this rule.
You know, as we'll talk about
when we get to Xerox PARC.
The group needs to have
a continuous learning
environment.
So, in other words, they're
all learning from each other,
and they need to have a setting
by which they can bring out
each other's skill sets
and teach each other
on a continuous kind of basis.
And Oppenheimer provides some
interesting insights on this.
I think those are
kind of key rules.
And then, we're going to
turn now to our colleagues
to present their
particular great group.
So, we'll get the three kind
of earlier great groups will
each of you all will
present on those
and kind of get those
out on the table.
And you've got about 10 minutes
or so to tell their story
and explain their
rule set and what
additional rules they
kind of came up with that
are relevant here.
Clear so far?
All right.
So, Martin, why don't
we do Edison first?
MARTIN: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
There's Edison.
MARTIN: I think
with Edison, it's
important to kind of look
at him as an individual
first, and then also the
organization and group
he created after.
So, Edison came from a
relatively poor family.
He kind of made his own ways.
He's kind of like the original
self-made American inventor.
He started off self-taught
because he was kind of deaf,
so he couldn't really
learn in a school setting.
So, his self-taught
him math at home.
And so, that also gives
him an original way
of looking at problems.
He's not really used to
following social construct
as well.
And then, he gets a
job on the railroad
where as he's going
on the railroad
he sees a lot of
different things.
So, he's somebody
who kind of becomes
street smart as time evolves.
And he is inventing
things and learning
while he's on the railroad.
So, there's a funny story about
him having his own little mini
lab on a railroad which,
you know, it's pretty funny.
And so people wouldn't
steal certain chemicals,
he would like list
them as poison.
And then, so that's kind
of like his development
into adolescence.
And as he grows up and
kind of becomes an adult,
he gets relatively lucky.
But he has all these hours
of experience of inventing,
and he invents this
thing called the--
let me get the name here--
it's like the
quadruple telegraph
which what he sells
for what would
be the equivalent
of $200,000 today.
And that's what he uses
as the initial money
investment to make his
lab at Menlo Park, which
is considered, I think, one
of the first great American
research labs.
So, for him, it's
pretty interesting
because he's relatively
street smart understands,
the technology,
understands what he
doesn't know about the
science, and understands
the individuals.
So, as he comes in, he is
kind of a strong leader.
But what he does that's unique
is he finds different people
with different talents.
Not just academic, but also
people who can build things.
People that have
experience shipping.
People have leadership
abilities because he's
kind of had this kind of--
His 10,000 hours
isn't just science,
it's also been the
ability to interact
with a variety of people
and see how they actually
work in a real-life setting.
So I think what would
be interesting with him
was to go through the Bennis.
Kind of some of
the characteristics
of strong groups and
kind of relate them
to how he did it at Menlo Park.
Let me see if I can find this.
OK.
So, need certain conditions.
Focus.
So, Menlo Park
was really a ranch
that he originally bought
with his house in the back.
So, being the leader, he
kind of took it upon himself
to place it near his home.
But, he actually rarely
went into his house.
So, his wife lived in the
back, and he would always
be in the shop of Menlo Park
always working with the people
there.
To the point that one time,
he walked into his house
and his wife hadn't seen
him in about a week.
So, she thought it
was an intruder.
So that kind of focus.
Just to give it--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
She almost shot him.
Right?
MARTIN: Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, I don't
want to imply, but yeah.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MARTIN: Light bulb moment.
Have everyone in one place.
As I mentioned, they're
there in Menlo Park.
And he has these
great individuals.
Isolate them.
They are kind of isolated
in their own skill set,
but they can always collaborate.
It is a flat model.
There's only really two
floors I think in Menlo Park.
And then, he did choose
to expand slightly later,
but it wasn't highly isolated.
No distractions.
They were away from what I
would say like other people.
So it was an island.
Atmosphere stress,
they did have stress
because they did have deadlines.
And they're also very prolific.
I forget how many patents.
You might know the number.
I know Edison has around 1000
patents by time of his death.
I think-- I don't want to give
a wrong number because it's
hard to find, but
I know that they're
very prolific in terms of
assuming a patent like a week.
Something like that.
Because the talent, but
also like I mentioned,
Edison was street
smart, so they knew
but things are kind of ready to
invent and put out there right
away.
So, most of the patents
were all utility
based in terms of mechanical,
electrical, magnetism.
And a lot of them--
I think there's only 14 patents
for Menlo Park for something
that was design related.
So, it's very much focusing
on what they were good at,
which was kind of this
applied science area.
Island with bridge to mainland.
They were the island.
The ability to
sell, Edison already
knew from past
inventions, so that
wasn't as much of a problem.
But it does fit that
framework roughly.
I would say.
Winning underdogs.
They did have competitors.
They're not as famous
as, you know, apples
competitors or other companies.
But they did know that
at this time period,
a lot of different people
were making inventions
to run electricity, and
it was a market that there
was a lot of
competitors coming in,
and you really had
to fight to win.
Even though they were utilities,
the dynamics of the markets
weren't as they are now.
Have an enemy.
That goes back to their
opponents optimism.
And not really realistic.
They would just try
things to try things,
to see if they would work.
And sometimes, they would
work or would not work out.
Right person for the right job.
Give them what they need.
They had a ton of resources.
Let me bring up a example.
A newspaper article
printed in 1887
reveals the seriousness
of his claim
saying the lab contain
8,000 kinds of chemicals,
every kind of screw made,
every size of needle
every kind of quarter wired,
hair of humans, horses, hogs,
cows, rabbits, goats,
minxes, camels,
so silk in every
texture, cocoons,
various kinds of hooves,
shark's teeth, deer's horns,
tortoise shells, cork
resin, varnish and oil,
ostrich feathers, peacock tails,
jet, amber, rubber, all auras,
and the list goes on.
So I mean that--
AUDIENCE: Why?
AUDIENCE: He was a hoarder.
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MARTIN: Yeah, well,
at the time there's
different theories of science.
Right.
So, they weren't
as refined, so they
would try different things.
And also, he probably
left room for things
that weren't mainstream
science at the time
to try different theories
because if you have
an expert that says, oh, I
know how to do this and this,
but it's not explained by the
current theory of science,
he would still give
them a shot usually.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So, these presumably
are all for filaments
to get across the two
electrical poles.
He's got to find the
right filament that's--
MARTIN: And I think
what the right problem
at the right time.
Like Edison wasn't
the first person
to create the light bulb.
He perfected the design so
it can last longer than,
I forget if it was five
seconds or five minutes,
so it could last for
extended periods of time.
So, that's another gamble,
finding the right problem
at the right time.
And it's something that
we see in tech a lot.
Like the I think the
Newton from Apple
was like an original was
pretty much the iPad,
but it just was the wrong time.
Also, I think Oracle
came out with something
that was like the book
like in the late 90s,
and it didn't sell
because it was too early.
And not a lot of people on the
internet yet, and there wasn't
Wi-Fi.
So, I think those
kind of showcase
some of the examples of
how Menlo Park was run.
It was definitely kind
of like a hierarchy
where Edison kind of
made the decisions,
but he would make
more hard decisions,
which is important
as well because it
gets rid of complexity.
And allows people-- usually,
if you make a quick decision,
it's better group because
you'll go that way,
and if it doesn't work you
just move on to the next thing,
but people aren't debating
about, oh, let's do this
or that for a long
period of time.
So, there's also when
you're there, just
focusing on doing the work.
So, those are some of
the characteristics
of this great group
in Menlo Park.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
You know, maybe we
ought to do Q&A now rather
than kind of bunch these up.
Let me just share a couple
of thoughts with you
from these photographs.
That's the invention factory.
And then, back behind this is
the house, the old farmhouse
where Edison theoretically
lived with his wife,
although he's spending
almost all his time here.
And that's the team.
Right.
That's the group.
And there's the group,
right, on the first floor
of this building.
And it's an interesting
amalgam of talents.
So, there's some engineers
and scientists in here,
but there's tremendous artisans.
Since they have to
invent the vacuum tube,
in effect, they have
a great glass blower.
Right.
So, it's a very
interesting mix of we
call them experimentalists
and theoreticians are,
you know, combined
in this space.
But a remarkable ability
to work together,
and Martin has well described
some of the rules that
apply to them.
They're having a good time.
So, they're often up ridiculous
hours of day and night.
And they have a, you know,
they have an old stove.
And after midnight, they
gather around the stove.
So, rap has not been invented,
but they shout doggerel poetry
to each other that's humorous
at the top of their lungs.
And Mrs. Edison
brings by cherry pies.
All right.
So, they feast around
the old pot-bellied stove
eating pie and shouting
doggerel poetry at each other.
It gives you an idea of
the kind of adventure
that they were having together.
And on the island bridge
point that Martin made,
a key set of relationships
that Edison was able to form
was that telegraphing in
effect like quadruplexing
by telegraph.
The ability to send multiple
messages over the same line.
That really enables the stock
ticker and a tremendous amount
of exchange of financial
information for stock
exchanges.
So, buying could
occur at a distance.
You could place orders from
all over the country, which
really is foundational
for Wall Street.
So, people like JP Morgan
completely understood
the power of this and have
a relationship with Edison.
So, the Edison crowd is
all off in this rural farm
on an island, but Edison has
got a bridge back to JP Morgan.
So, when they figure out the
light bulb, and the system that
goes with it, which
I'll get to in a second,
he's got a way to reach a
decision maker who can actually
stand up to technology.
Right.
And that's really crucial.
So, that invention earlier
that he came up with
is really the enabler
for this whole project.
They have to ship
because, as Martin says,
they've got a limited amount
of money, which they're burning
through by purchasing every
bizarre thing you can think of,
as you just ran through
the great list of.
So, it's driven by
the need to ship.
They're going to have
to get this thing done
before their money runs out.
So, they're working all hours
with incredible intensity
to try and do it.
This is not just the
invention of the light bulb.
They have to invent--
a light bulb is worthless
without an electrical system
to go with it.
So, one of the things
that Edison and his crew
figure out they
essentially have to invent
the entire public utility model.
So, they got a light
bulb, which is a useless
product unless you have an
electrical system go with it.
So, they have to think
through power systems.
They have to think
through safety.
They have to figure
out generators.
They have to figure out
the organizational model
for utilities in order to
understand how this whole thing
is going to work.
So, they've got a
dream product that's
going to displace, you know, gas
lighting, which was incredibly
dangerous, blew up all the time,
with a much safer, inherently
safer system, which provided
much better quality light.
So, they've got a
dream product, but it
doesn't work unless they
do the entire innovation
system for electricity along
with it, which is really
what their accomplishment is.
Right.
It's understanding and
being able to put into place
the whole system, and then
using their bridge back
to the financial world
to get it financed.
So, those are just a few points
building on Martin's, you know,
good summary, but let's do some
questions on the Edison group.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah,
why don't you fire some out?
OK.
MARTIN: How effective would
an Edison-style research lab
be today?
So, there's like a really
good show called pure genius
right now where it's
a billionaire who
like makes a hospital
where he kind of does
something like this.
But I just wonder if anybody
had any interesting thoughts.
AUDIENCE: I feel
like it definitely
depends on the application.
Like, what they're
interested in working on.
Because I feel like
this translates
well when the capital
expenses are lower,
but if you're trying
to do research
on energy or large
infrastructure stuff,
I feel like it would be
hard for a single person
to finance that today.
Like, even this is
pretty impressive
that you could build such a
complex company from a garage
basically.
But, I mean we see
like Apple essentially
started a similar process.
So, that's something that kind
of can start small and grow.
I think it could
still work today.
AUDIENCE: I don't really
see very many differences
between this and Facebook.
It seems very similar very--
well, but again it follows
that model of the quote
unquote great group because
it's everyone's focused,
you've got a ton of
people that are only
working on the project.
They've got all the
resources they need.
And they just like to work,
and they have a great time.
MARTIN: So, say like
somebody is trying
to do this for like fusion,
like instead of the Manhattan
Project, it's the
Manhattan Project
2.0 where they're trying to
figure out a fusion energy
device.
Do you think a small
group of talented people
will be able to do it?
MAX: I think it'd be awesome,
and I'd love to do it.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: You know,
Max, I think you're right.
This is the iconic picture.
That's the group.
And it's all in a
room, and they're all
in rich communication
with each other.
I think that
picture gets carried
through into most
of the great groups
that we're going to talk about.
MARTIN: And then
another question
I had based on this group
was, do you think universities
should focus on getting
a variety of skill sets
to interact with
the researchers?
Because usually it's
academics, or they're
used to doing
research, but they only
see a problem a certain way.
Versus somebody who would
be more street smart
or has a more technical
ability to just build things,
they would-- it might
lead to richer solutions.
MAX: So what's the question?
MARTIN: So should
universities focus
on getting people that
aren't from universities
that are talented in science?
So it could be electricians.
It can be material scientists.
MAX: Oh, so [INAUDIBLE]
MARTIN: People who do things,
rather than just people who
have gone to college.
AUDIENCE: To teach,
is that what you mean?
MARTIN: No, not to teach.
To collaborate in
a research setting.
AUDIENCE: OK, OK.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I think it's
really an important question,
because we've begun to talk
about the increasing economic
role of universities, through
the Bayh-Dole Act, for example,
and the fact that universities
now control patents on the--
and the researchers
control the patents
on their federally-funded
research.
And the pressure's
on universities
to play more and more
of an economic role.
As the old historic
industrial labs come down,
the university role grows.
If this is the iconic
picture, are there
settings in universities
that look like this,
or is it only two or
three people in the room?
I think that's a really
intriguing question.
Martin, what do you think?
MARTIN: I think
you should probably
have people, just because a
lot of things, in theory--
well, and another is, if
you think about the world
in terms of theories that
we haven't discovered yet
or things we haven't
discovered and our theories
aren't perfect.
The way I would see it
is somebody who has--
say somebody who's
built an electrical grid
and played around with
different materials,
they have 10,000
hours in things that
might not have a theory
for it yet-- they just
know it happens.
So they might be able
to say, well, you think,
theoretically, this
is going to happen.
This is what you're certain of.
But based on some of
the stuff I've seen--
I've seen this.
Maybe we should just try it out.
And I think that might be a
really interesting proposition.
AUDIENCE: I wonder if
it makes a difference
though whether you're inventing
a scientific advancement,
or if it's just a product
with maybe no new technology,
but putting things together
that consumers want.
So I think with Facebook, I
consider it more like a product
not necessarily
invented something new.
Whereas with Edison, they
said he had an intuitive
understanding of Ohm's
law and putting together
the light bulb.
But I feel like
now it's probably
even more of a challenge to make
scientific advancements just
from tinkering around, just
because a lot has already
been done.
MARTIN: Yeah.
But I would say there's
also an opportunity,
because if you look at--
there's waves of technology,
like it's STS theme or certain
ways of doing things come into
fashion, and then they don't.
So a lot of the great
scientists of the 1800s
built things, and would
just build things and not
really try to come up with
a mathematical theory.
Versus today, you come up
with a mathematical theory,
and then go and try it.
So there's less people
just trying random things.
So there might be
a huge opportunity
there because, with all the new
insights and all the new data,
you could try
interesting things.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: All
right, so why don't we
leave Edison and
shift over to Beth,
who is going to do Oppenheimer?
BETH: OK, so again before I
go into the Manhattan Project
specifically, I wanted to
talk a little bit about Robert
Oppenheimer a person.
He had a pretty
fascinating life--
a little bit tragic, but he
really contributed a lot.
So he went to Harvard and
finished his chemistry degree
in three years, and then
started on a PhD in physics
at Cambridge under JJ
Thompson, who maybe
is someone you've heard of.
But completed his
painting in Germany,
where he had the opportunity
to meet a lot of really
famous scientists of the day--
Bohr, Heisenberg,
[INAUDIBLE],, et cetera.
After that, he went to work
at Berkeley as a professor.
So he was really
building his network
and knew really all the
preeminent physicists
of his day worked
there [INAUDIBLE]
Something that will continue
to haunt him and affect
how he works is that he did
have multiple affiliations left
organizations while he was--
especially while he was younger.
So as the Red Scare
comes about in the '50s,
and even as he's working
on the Manhattan Project,
there are a lot of times
that these affiliations come
into question, and people
doubt his loyalties.
So that's something that--
it's just interesting to note.
And obviously, he
was selected to lead
the development of the
atomic bombs at Los Alamos.
I do just want to talk
a little bit about what
happened to him after
the war, before we
spent the majority of the time
talking about his war efforts.
So in 1947, after
the war, he started
working in Princeton at the
Institute for Advanced Studies.
So that's where
Einstein was, as well.
So he was working with a
bunch of really smart people.
But then in 1949, he's called
to the House Un-American
Activities Committee.
And in 1953, his security
clearance was revoked.
So a lot of scientists
did come speak out
on his behalf,
including Vannevar Bush,
Edward Teller, who will
make an appearance later
in my discussion--
said some comments that
weren't expressly negative,
but were very much did not hold
Oppenheimer's cause at all.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: It
really led to his downfall.
BETH: Yeah.
They were kind of wishy-washy
in what he actually said,
but it was used
against him a lot,
and eventually it really
contributed to the fact
that he was no longer allowed
to have a security clearance
and really was pushed out of
the political field of science.
So as a result of
that, he withdrew
from political activity--
kind of because
he was forced to.
So he moved to the
US Virgin Islands.
And he worked a little
bit independently
on the nuclear field, but lost
a lot of his influence outside
of the scientific community.
So within the
scientific community,
I think a lot of people still
held him in high regard,
but his opinions and his work
wasn't really listened to
by people outside.
Finally, in 1963, he got
a political rehabilitation
when JFK awarded him
the Enrico Fermi Award.
This obviously didn't
leave him much time
to contribute after that,
because unfortunately, he
was diagnosed with lung cancer
and died a few years after.
Yeah, he was a bit of a
chain smoker, unforunately.
But it's kind of sad to
see this downfall of,
as well discuss in the next
slides, a great leader who
stepped up to the job
in a time of crisis.
All right, so now for the main
focus, the Manhattan Project.
So the picture on the left is
an aerial view the Los Alamos
laboratory, and on
the right and some
famous names of people
who worked there,
including Bohr,
Feynman, and Fermi.
So the Manhattan
Project's goal, as I think
most people are aware of, is--
was to build the nuclear
bomb, essentially
before the Nazis did.
That was the
ultimate motivation.
And it really is an
example of a great group.
As I'll go through
the next slide,
it really ticks off
a bunch of the boxes,
because in a very
short amount of time,
with pretty young group
working really hard,
they were able to achieve this.
And obviously, the
nuclear bomb comes
laden with a lot of ethical
and values questions, which
I think would be
interesting to spend
most of this time talking on.
Bennis mentions in his work
that professor described
that you do run into this
potential challenge of,
what if a great
group comes together
to do something that
is not very great?
And so from the
perspective of Americans,
we can view this
achievement as purely great,
but-- or at the time, it
was perceived as great.
Now, it's obviously murkier.
But had this great group been
a group of German scientists
at the time, it would have been
a much scarier position for us.
So I'll come back to that.
I just wanted to tick
off a few of the elements
of a great group, and talk
about Oppenheimer's role
specifically.
First, Oppenheimer really
was a charismatic leader.
Before this, he hadn't really
had much leadership experience
outside of his lab itself-- so
overseeing graduate students.
And a lot of people questioned
his choice as the leader
in this project.
They weren't sure he had the
right temperament or experience
to do it.
And a lot of his colleagues
and people who worked there did
see a noticeable change in how
he worked before versus how
he worked at Los Alamos, that
he really kind of stepped up
to the task and was able to be
a very influential and effective
leader in this position.
Since he knew basically
everyone in the physics field,
he was able to attract
some really great talent,
and definitely wasn't
concerned with finding
people who might have
more knowledge in one area
than he did.
He really emphasized the
open access to information.
So they would have meetings--
I forget if it was
weekly or monthly--
I think weekly-- where people
would share their research
with each other so
that everyone had
an idea of what was going on.
Some of the other
hands-off approaches
were the flexible working
hours and the freedom
to work on things
you're passionate about.
So Teller, the guy from
the previous slide,
really wanted to
develop the H bomb,
and was pretty distracted
from his work that
was really applicable
to the work
that they were doing at hand.
But Oppenheimer
realized that the way
he was going to
be most effective
was to just let
Teller go off and work
on what he cared about.
And so he allowed
people some freedom
in judging what they
should be doing.
With this example, there
is a clear mission,
and there is a clear adversary,
so that was a very strong
motivating factor.
There was a sense of camaraderie
between the scientists.
It did help that they
had a lot in common.
It was mostly young men
interested in science.
I think the average age
was 25, so it was just a--
kind of the same thing of
hanging out around the stove.
They all lived and were
pretty isolated in Los Alamos
without much interaction.
MAX: That's something
I thought that was odd.
If they're all age 25, doesn't
that mean that a lot of them
don't even have their PhD yet?
BETH: So I think, from
my interpretation,
people used to get their PhDs
slightly faster and younger.
So Oppenheimer had his at 23.
So I don't know--
MAX: He graduated in
three years though.
BETH: Yeah.
MARTIN: He went college early.
AUDIENCE: Maybe a lot of them
are graduate students too,
because a lot of the
people at the Rad Lab
were graduate students who
are brought in by the--
Lawrence and--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: They brought their
graduate students with them.
20 or 21.
BETH: Yeah, so young
group of people
who had a lot of
energy and enthusiasm,
and really didn't have much
else that they could do,
because they're in the middle of
somewhat nowhere in New Mexico.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
They're on a mesa top.
BETH: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Island.
BETH: Yeah, very
much so an island.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yes,
the ultimate island.
BETH: Both for security purposes
and to keep them focused.
I do think they had a bit of
the underdog attitude, as well.
Whether it was true
or not, they perceived
that they were behind the
Germans in development
of the bomb, and
so they were very
motivated to try to catch up
and to become the top dog.
It did have a pretty
casual atmosphere.
It wasn't very hierarchical.
There was a little
division as possible.
I think the book mentioned
that Oppenheimer wrote out
his ideal sketch on
a piece of paper,
and someone asked how
it should be organized.
So it was pretty freeform.
And lastly, he did a lot
to maintain enthusiasm
and to keep people excited
about working there,
both the scientists
themselves and the families
that they brought with them.
So part of that was everyone
had to take some days off,
so that had some semblance
of work life balance.
There were a lot
of social events.
Oppenheimer hosted some parties.
And I think something
really interesting
that he did was to help the
women that were brought to Los
Alamos, mostly as spouses--
a few scientists,
but mostly spouses--
to get more engaging
jobs than they
might have been
able to otherwise.
So rather than having them
stuck at home, isolated
as housewives, he
would bring in people
who would do the house chores
for them, so that they could
get jobs as administrators,
or more challenging work
that would keep them happier
to be there, as well.
But this work obviously
raised many ethical questions.
And these are four
scientists that I picked out
who discussed some of these.
So first is Niels Bohr.
He escaped from Denmark
and came over to the Allies
during World War II.
And he very much supported
the idea of open access
to information, not just
between Britain and the US,
but including the Soviet
Union in there, as well.
He was afraid that leaving
the Soviet Union out
of all of this work was
going to lead to an arms race
after World War II.
He was probably correct.
Another interesting
person working on this
is Joseph Rotblat.
So he quit Los
Alamos after the--
not after the war
that should say--
after Germany was defeated,
because he thought that there
was no purpose to continue
to study the bomb,
if that was their goal was to
have the bomb before Germany
did, to protect themselves.
He didn't think that
developing the bomb further
was necessary after
Germany was defeated.
And then both Wilson
and Feynman, I think,
are quoted again in
that Bennis article.
So when they do the first
successful test at Trinity,
everyone's out
there celebrating.
This is the culmination
of all their work,
so they're really
excited about this.
But Feynman sees Robert Wilson,
and he's like desponded.
It's a terrible
thing that we made.
And Feynman points
out that they all
got caught up in this
excitement, this enthusiasm
for achieving their goal,
that they kind of lost sight
of what their goal would do.
And so that's, I think, a very
important part of the story
that makes it a little different
from some of the other ones
that we'll study
today, is that there
are a lot of potential
downsides to the work
that this great group did.
I think it's pretty
clear that it
was great in its
characteristics,
but I think it'd be
interesting to discuss
what the repercussions
of that could be.
So one question before we go
too much into the ethical debate
about Oppenheimer himself--
so as I mentioned,
a lot of people
didn't have much
faith that Oppenheimer
would be an effective leader.
And it didn't seem like there
was a little bit of a learning
curve for him to
understand what was
realistic in what could work.
And so one question that
came to my mind was,
how long should a trial period
be for a leader in a situation?
How do you decide this
person's not cutting it,
we need to replace him,
versus ruling out people
just because they haven't
adapted really quickly?
So if you have any
thoughts on that--
MAX: Well, I suppose it
depends on the situation.
But here, if you're
in a war scenario
where you have a
couple of years,
and that could be the
difference-- and even
a couple of months could be
the difference between today
and Man in the High Castle.
For those who don't know,
it's an alternate universe
where Nazi Germany wins.
So I guess in that case, I would
have given him like two months
to figure out can he change,
is showing improvement?
If he isn't ideally
suited at the beginning,
can he adapt to the situation?
And even then even,
if he can adapt,
can adapt quickly enough--
AUDIENCE: Could I ask-- who
would conduct a performance
review?
BETH: In this situation,
he was kind of subject
to the Army's approval, as well.
He was working kind of paired
up with General Groves,
so I think that he would
have had a lot of say,
if he thought Oppenheimer
was doing a terrible job.
But as far as who his
ultimate boss was--
MAX: [INAUDIBLE] I'd
say some of his other--
his subordinates
would also definitely
have some weight because then--
they're all very accomplished
scientists in their field,
so their opinions
certainly have meaning.
So I think, if they
worked with Groves,
they could-- if they wanted to,
they could get him pushed out.
AUDIENCE: Also going off that
point, I think, as a leader,
it's really important to
recognize when you might have
some deficiencies,
and really learn how
to delegate to other people.
In the beginning, I think
the article mentioned
he wasn't very good at
budgeting things or managing
the logistics of
establishing the town.
So maybe if he could
recognize really early on,
oh, I can't do this, I need to
appoint someone else to do it,
I think that's also an important
part of being a good leader.
And to be honest,
it's something that
probably should be established
early on, especially in such
a time-sensitive project.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: That's just
a thought to contribute here
on his leadership style.
Martin brought us through
Edison, and in some ways,
Edison is a 19th century
figure with a certain kind of--
who believes in
his own seniority,
his own kind of authority.
And he's something of
an authoritarian figure
with that community.
They do share things and
they are all up late at night
together, but there's
no questioning
about who the leader is.
Oppenheimer's got a very
different leadership style.
And correct me, Beth, if you've
got a different view on this.
But there was a phrase in
the book reading about him,
which was, he was like
a bee spreading pollen.
In the words, he had the ability
to go from group to group
to group-- because this is
organized with teams working
on particular parts
of the project--
help them think of
their core ideas,
and then share ideas
other groups that
would help influence them.
And I think that turned out
to be a really critical--
this is a large operation.
This is not going
to fit in one room.
Now, he did, as you
mentioned, Beth,
pull them together
into the auditorium
weekly for really in-depth
exchanges and presentations
so that they all kind of
knew what was going on,
they were all in on
what was happening.
But he plays a critical role
in moving from team to team,
trading the ideas
back and forth that
will help move them along
and help advance them.
And in some ways, that's
the critical function
that I think he plays.
Does that add up
with your views?
BETH: Yeah.
I was thinking of one
other point in the book
where it said his
talent was finding
the talents of other people
and using those effectively.
So yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
So that's a different
leadership model,
but in this setting, an
absolutely critical one,
I think.
Because all of these pieces
have to work together,
and unless they're
all advancing,
it's not going to happen.
And he plays a
really critical role
in getting those pieces
advancing together.
BETH: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Yeah, absolutely.
BETH: So again,
going back to what
Bennis talked about with
these great groups that
may be towing a dangerous line.
How could one stop the
seemingly runaway tendency
of great groups that
they start crossing
an ethical or moral line?
It seems like they have
so much momentum going.
What responsibility do
the scientists within
have-- or anyone within
it, not scientists--
to slow it down and rethink it?
How would you go
about doing that?
AUDIENCE: Well, I
almost think it's
in the eye of the beholder,
because this one is pretty--
well, even this is murky--
but it's pretty cut and dried.
They made it a huge
killing device.
But I'm presenting on Craig
Venter and the decoding
of the human genome,
and a lot of people
might argue that that is an
out-of-control topic, as well.
So I think it's kind
of your perspective
that you're coming from.
MARTIN: I think also, we--
especially in this
presentation, you kind of
glanced over Heisenberg.
So it wasn't just,
we're building a gun
so we can shoot somebody.
It's like, somebody
else is building gun
and they're about
to shoot us, and we
should be the-- we need to be
the first ones to be ready.
Because Heisenberg
seemed way more prepared.
They were getting reports.
There's this great documentary
called "Oppenheimer vs
Heisenberg" by American
Genius where they go over
how they thought Heisenberg
was much farther ahead,
and sometimes they would fake
reports to make it seem--
so for them, yeah, there
were these ethical questions.
And the interesting thing
about this great group
is that most the people that
joined the group were very much
pacifists or left.
So they weren't people who
wanted to build weapons.
But at this time period,
the stresses around
them influence them to have
to build this because they
knew that, if they--
even though my beliefs are
this, if I don't do this,
it could affect people
that I do care about.
And it's just because
of my beliefs,
so maybe I should change
my beliefs to do this.
I think the ethical question
was very much after they figured
out Heisenberg wasn't--
his lab had already blown up
and it wasn't working out.
Why didn't they stop?
And a lot of it is that
they already had come into--
they had so much momentum that
they wanted to be prepared.
But also how are you
defining a horrible weapon?
It's a weapon that
can take down cities,
and how many times
had it ultimately been
used since the time period?
And how many deaths have been
created because of it compared
to other things too?
I think there's a
huge focus on it
because it's a weapon
of high magnitude,
so it's under a higher scrutiny.
But also I'd want to look into
the data of how many people
have actually being
killed by nuclear arms
compared to other--
AUDIENCE: Or it can be a
weapon or a source of energy.
The human genome can be a
source of biological weaponry
or a huge source of
knowledge for science.
So you have these caveats
with a lot of the things
that the great groups have done.
MAX: That's kind of
the point of science.
Science is morally neutral.
You're just learning
about the nature of atoms,
the nature of nuclei, and what
kind of chain reaction exists.
That just depends on the
people that actually have it,
and who discovers
it, and how they
decide to fund it and use it.
So that's going to happen with
any technology that exists.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
But Max, we're
moving here from science to a
very clear, specific technology
project.
But I think, Martin, you
make an important point.
This physics community
before World War II
is a relatively small community,
and the group that gets
assembled here, they
all know each other.
They've all been in
communication prior to the war.
And they knew
Heisenberg very well,
and they knew how
unbelievably talented he was.
And they thought he had at least
a couple of years head start.
And I think they all
realized that if Heisenberg
was successful in doing this--
we talked about the Rad Lab
as a war-winning technology--
radar.
This is war-ending.
If Germany developed
this first, the war
would be over like that.
It would be over.
And now is an option which
I think the group certainly,
as a whole, felt was
completely unacceptable.
So that motivates
everything up until April.
And then what's going to happen?
So that's a critical
moment, but it's not
really until after the
actual use of the weapon
that I think this community
begins to think hard about this
and about the consequences.
There are some
exceptions, like Rothblat.
But that's when
Oppenheimer has to confront
what the implications are and
begin to think about how to--
because they've all been
involved in development of it.
The physics community
comes together
as a political body, in a way,
and starts to try and push
the government to
think about how we're
going to deal with these
staggering technologies
and their implications.
Does that add up, Beth?
BETH: Yeah.
It does.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Do want to give us
some closing thoughts
about Oppenheimer
and what's important
about the group?
BETH: Sure.
So Oppenheimer's
experience is definitely
quintessential for when--
for how effective
technology advancements
can be under more pressures.
So I think we discussed
a few weeks ago,
is it possible to replicate
this sense of urgency
and this progress
under times of peace?
And if we had a Los
Alamos of fusion,
would we be able
to get it to work?
Would we ever be
able to even get
funding to do that without
some kind of wartime need?
It's definitely something
I've been thinking about.
They had so much money, so
many resources, and so much
talent in a small
area, working hard,
and they were able
to achieve something.
But again, it was mostly
motivated-- pretty much
entirely motivated by the war.
And I think we just
keep coming back to
how can we make these
advancements when we
don't have that same impetus?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
Good point to close on.
AUDIENCE: So today
I'm going to present
on the several groups
that get involved
in the process of inventing
interactive computers.
So in the very beginning,
when the first computer
was invented, it was so big,
expensive, and only accessible
to scientists and
engineers that there's
no one that ever imagined
something like this before us
will be so much--
no one imagined we would be so
much relying on these devices.
But then Vannevar
Bush was the one--
had this mission
that computer can
be some kind of intimate
supplement to memory,
that he named as
[INAUDIBLE] vision.
And he presented it in
front of all the scientists
at the summit and he kind of
inspired one of the scientists
in Philippines named
Douglas Engelbart.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Yes, Doug Engelbart.
AUDIENCE: Engelbart.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
AUDIENCE: And they
got funding from NASA,
and they started to
get hands on images
on how to have this
interactivity between computer
and the users.
Then the invention of Windows,
and the mouse, and the screen
was successful by 1968.
Bob Taylor and Alan
Kay had this group
at Palo Alto Research Center.
They were under the ax--
I don't know how
to pronounce it.
AUDIENCE: Xerox?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Xerox, yes.
AUDIENCE: Xerox, yeah.
Xerox a corporation
with already having
a lot of scientific investment.
So PARC, P-A-R-C,
was under Xerox,
and today we're going to focus
on their principles on [their
recruitment of this great group.
So Bob Taylor had--
was the real boss of PARC
lab and the principal
that he was is existing
on is that there's
no good scientists--
there's only great ones.
So he had very strict selection
of scientists and participants.
The way that he built
this team bonding--
team spirit is that, during
the selection of scientists,
he also requests participants--
the applicants to present
in front of the whole staff,
so people who are already
part of this group
will find oh, this is
an interesting person
and we would like to
have him in our team.
And so whoever get
assigned in this team
would feel this
sense of recognition.
And I think this
is something that
might be lacking in a
lot of science groups
today because there's
always this fear of having
new members coming
in, and they're
so talented that they will
replace the previous members.
And this kind of
fear might hinder
the next round of innovation.
And the other
principle that Taylor
has the mobility of talents.
He introduced market mechanism
where they are now selecting
projects, but they're--
they're not selecting
the talents,
but they're selecting
the projects
where, in a sense,
whoever finds this project
interesting can drop
whatever they're doing
and join the other product.
So the interesting projects get
more talent and get moved on,
and those less interesting
ones you get [INAUDIBLE]..
And another key
feature of his team
is that the structure of
the team was also flat.
There's no influence of politics
in this group of science.
Another feature they had is
this group meeting every week.
So it is the only
compulsory thing,
that you have to attend
this kind of weekly meeting
where you bring your beanbags
and every project will present
their recent discoveries.
And some of the lessons
learned in one project
might be crucial to the things
going on in another team.
And they exchange these
ideas, and really helped
the entire lab to develop.
That is the beanbags.
Just I will mention
the role of the leader,
and how good he can serve the
group of talents in his team
and be loyal to--
be responsible to
the needs of the team
is also very important.
For PARC, there's
a time that they
wanted to have access to
different hardwares where the--
Xerox--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN Xerox.
AUDIENCE: Xerox--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Xerox, yes.
AUDIENCE: --didn't really
wanted to give the permission,
bit the leader was very
assertive his demand,
and really threaten
if you didn't allow--
if you don't allow us to have--
to invent our own
hardwares, I will just quit.
And eventually,
they get permission
and they design their own
hardwares and softwares.
And of course, this team was--
they're group of
scientists that's
really into whatever
they're doing,
that they don't
see how they want
to ship this to the mainland.
They don't see how this can be--
should be commercialized.
Therefore, some other team
picked up this really well,
and it's Apple, Steve Jobs.
So Steve Jobs saw
this opportunity
of having this
interactive and easy,
the user-friendly version of
computer being commercialized
in the market.
And he understand that that
is the future of computing,
and inspired his team to just
do this in a very [INAUDIBLE]
So Steve Jobs was able to
inspire his team that they're--
in a way that they are
doing something secretive.
They cannot tell anyone
else what they are doing.
And they were working
like 100 hours per week
that's really intense,
and also escalated.
He also has this obsession,
the elegance of this design.
I think that also explains
how Apple users are
so loyal to this company.
Then there's this also
saying that Steve Jobs
criticism to his employer
sometimes can be abusive.
And maybe it helped to build
this innovative environment
and give the pressure to get
things done, but in a way
that maybe he's also
driving people away.
So there's the downsides of
his management principles,
also this breaking
down of marriage
and other relationships.
It can be argued that
maybe this personality also
helped to get this delivery
of Macintosh to the market.
But I would like
to hear your voice.
And there's some
question that's really--
that's been popping
up in my mind
while I was doing
these readings.
What is your view?
Are some inventions or
technical advancements that--
they are inevitable
for human revolution?
Maybe the invention of fire
or the use of tools in hunting
are so crucial to human survival
that they will eventually
be discovered.
But there are other things like
maybe the desired computer.
Maybe Vannevar Bush
didn't point or have
this vision of
personal computer,
but it's something entirely
different, but equally amazing.
Maybe we are having an
entirely different way
of communicating and
transporting everything,
but so much different.
So do you think there are
this category of innovations
that some of them are
crucial and inevitable,
there are other things
that are still--
we can still be without?
What are your thoughts?
MAX: So thinking back--
I think this goes back to
the previous reading that
was talking about how--
the 10,000 hours thing.
So a lot of inventions,
they seem to come by chance,
but they're not
actually by chance.
They come from people dedicating
thousands and thousands
of hours and years, and
completely restructuring
their very lives just
so they can try to make
some sort of development.
So I guess my first-- the
first example comes to mind
is penicillin.
Everyone's heard the story of
how he accidentally made it
and how he actually found
out that it works, because he
spilled some on a sandwich that
had mold on it or something.
That's the story I heard anyway.
So sometimes, maybe
occasionally chance
will help us find the invention
or hear about it more quickly.
For example, what's his
face-- who made the phone?
Graham Bell, thank you.
MARTIN: [INAUDIBLE]
MAX: Yeah, yeah.
Actually, apparently, he
was at the World Fair.
This is actually a
story I really love.
He was at the World's
Fair, and he--
when he was there, he happened
to get there really late,
so he couldn't get a table
in the electrical section.
So he had to get into some
sort of botany section
that was in this
musky attic somewhere.
And no one ever actually
saw his project,
because it was out of the way.
And apparently there
was a guy, some prince.
And Graham Bell used to teach
at a school for the deaf,
because I think his father
was deaf or something.
This prince was the one who
was leading the judges around
at the World's Fair.
The judges were tired
at the end of the day,
and they decided, OK, we'll
look at one more project
and go home.
And the prince happened
to see Bell, and they--
the prince obviously,
he greeted Bell.
He was like, oh, yeah, it's
great to see you again.
And then Bell showed
off his invention,
and the rest is history.
So sometimes it's chance,
but I feel like chance--
the invention isn't necessarily
chance, but rather the--
its rapid development
and commercialization,
that might be a little bit.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Let me draw
on some of the things, Luyao,
that you raised, and tie it
back to Max for a second.
So let me just go through some
of your interesting points
with some additional
perspectives.
So one, the point
you started with
was the Memex and
Vannever Bush's role
in creating the Memex, which
was really a fast retrieval
system for it microfilm
knowledge bases.
We could look at it now and
think about Windows and search
engines as derivative
technologies,
but that's really what
he was driving at.
And so it put a
picture up of something
that computing might be
able to undertake for us.
It's not that he was
able to achieve it.
So that was, I think, a
very interesting point
to start from.
Then you took us through
the story of Doug Engelbart,
just briefly.
We talked last week about--
and we'll talk more--
about JCR Licklider and the
role of DARPA in creating
these great group communities.
Engelbart is at Stanford
Research Institute, SRI,
and Licklider funds him.
And Engelbart is clearly
a remarkable talent.
Licklider has the ability at
DARPA to pick great groups
and support them, and Engelbart
is one that he comes up with.
SRI couldn't understand
what he was doing.
They were pretty dismissive.
But Licklider understood
back at the DARPA office,
and kept him funded.
So he does a demonstration,
as you point out,
of 1968, which is called
the mother of all demos.
And it was to a group of
computer freaks and computer
scientists.
And they're all
gathered in a room,
and Engelbart runs this series
of demonstrations about what
computing is going to be able
to do, and shows hypertext,
and he shows the mouse, and
he shows just a whole set
of capabilities
that computing is
going to be able to lead
to-- which none have ever
seen compiled before.
So that was a critical
visualization moment.
Bob Taylor also
worked for Licklider.
So he was a project
manager in DARPA--
again, another one of the
talents that Licklider
identified.
And Taylor goes
out to Xerox PARC
and is running what we would
call the personal computing
team.
And they develop--
Luyao, would you go to the
slide of the early Apple,
the early Mac?
Yeah, that one.
They develop something called
the Alto at Xerox PARC.
It does look a fair
amount like this.
It's got a cathode ray screen.
It's got a computer keyboard.
But it has all
these capabilities
that, in some ways, they have--
it has all of Engelbart's
capabilities and more--
and remarkable ability
to do data visualization.
It's fun to use, it's--
there having a
great time with it.
But because, as you pointed out,
of this island-bridge problem--
in other words, Xerox PARC
Palo Alto Research Center
is out there in California--
Xerox is in Rochester, New York.
It's making copying machines.
There just is no
connection between--
as you suggested, between
the group making copiers
in New York and these wild
computer scientists living
on beanbags.
And they just don't--
it doesn't happen.
The technology doesn't transfer.
Xerox has no idea
really what these--
what this incredible Xerox
PARC team visualized here
has accomplished.
They don't know how to
translate it in the marketplace,
so they miss the opportunity
of being Apple, and therefore,
the largest company in
the world at the moment.
So it's a painful
island-bridge problem
that they are never
able to resolve.
The head of R&D at Xerox PARC--
at Xerox, who had set up
Xerox PARC to begin with,
isn't able to help them
make that transition.
So it's the ultimate story of
the island-bridge not working.
And then, just to kind of carry
this story through, it's--
Jobs buys the rights
to essentially walk
through Xerox PARC,
and see the Alto,
and see what it's accomplished.
And he and his team go through
in the course of the afternoon.
It's not that they
take the technology.
They don't get the rights
to take the technology.
What they do is see what the
Alto is capable of doing.
And then they have a
picture of what's possible,
and then they work on
putting the Mac together
to realize that picture.
So there's great
technical accomplishment
and what they achieve.
But they do get the visions
on what gets put together.
So Luyao has led us in
this interesting track
of Vannevar Bush and Memex
to Doug Engelbart to--
I would throw in DARPA here
because they played such role--
but then to Bob Taylor comes
out of DARPA to lead Xerox PARC,
and then to Steve Jobs.
So there's a whole continuity.
And there's something
worth remembering,
which is that all
of these groups
stand on each other's shoulders.
These incredible
technology achievements
that lead to personal computing
just build, build, build,
and build.
And there's a series of
remarkable great groups here.
Is that a fair summary?
OK, now, let's
get back to your--
let me come to you
in a second, Steph.
But I think Luyao's question
is a really key one, that there
are inventions that
we have to have,
and then there's other stuff.
And how do we create that drive
to create the other stuff,
like computing?
We didn't have to have
personal computing.
The world got along with it for
a few million years without it.
What is it enables us to put
that on the list as a necessity
and really drive towards it?
How does that happen?
Is that a fair summary
of your question?
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
I think that's
where I disagree with
Max-- that I don't think
it's so much about
an inevitability,
because I think it's much more
about what Bill just stated,
that we stand on the
shoulders of giants,
and that necessitates
the continuance
of a momentum toward a
direction of something.
And I feel like
we had been going
towards the direction of the
personal computer for a very
long time, beginning
with the Gutenberg press,
and then the personal typewriter
that you could carry around,
and that people certainly
did carry around.
And then that gave
people the impression
that there could
be something better
and that there was a next step.
So I don't think it's so
much about inevitability or--
and I do think sometimes
chance does play a role,
but I think it's more so
about the continuation
of that momentum.
And that's why I think
it's important to analyze
where we are and where
we've been going,
and to think about the
interesting visions
that we can have within the
confines of that direction
in which we're
moving forward to.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So in a way, I
think what you're
both saying is that--
and we'll tie it back
into Beth's discussion
of Oppenheimer--
you build up this momentum
on a technology pathway,
and you can't turn
back the clock.
And that's what
Oppenheimer found.
When that project
reached culmination,
he probably wanted to
turn back the clock,
but there was no way.
That technology would
keep going on a pathway.
And maybe that's a way of
answering your question,
Luyao, that there's
certain-- there becomes
a certain inevitability about,
once you start launching down
a technology pathway,
that it's going
to have its own momentum,
whether it's a necessity
or not.
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: I think this is
getting philosophical--
whether or not there's
alternatives to history.
I realize there's another
part I didn't touch.
So this-- a lot of
principles we introduced
in these great groups
doesn't really act as models.
It's just these
factors adding together
make these things successful.
But how applicable are these
principles to the world today?
Personally, I find there's
over-commercialization
of a lot of
[INAUDIBLE] inventions.
And I don't know if it's true.
Also I saw a question
in our summary asking
with these lessons learned
from previous great groups,
how can these lessons be
applied to different scales
of production?
The great groups I assessed
are smaller groups,
and they're in the beginning
of figuring out how computer--
personal computer can work.
But in terms of bigger companies
like Google or Facebook,
are they--
how applicable are these lessons
to these bigger groups that
also requires innovation, but
having a more complex politics
in these groups?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah.
Look, I think that's
a crucial question.
And related to it is, once
you create a great group,
does it only do
one thing, or can I
keep moving on to
ongoing innovations?
And the number of times
that happens is not big.
But how could you create
a culture, particularly
within the larger
corporate organization,
that keeps innovating.
It's really a tricky problem.
AUDIENCE: We also hope
that these models can
be independent of the leader
and their personality,
and can be cated
in other fields.
Otherwise, it will always
be reliant on that leaders
to lead us [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: So when
I was reading this,
and in Bennis's whole
description of great groups,
I definitely have
a lot of concerns
with how the groups come about.
Like at PARC
especially, it was--
I forget.
Taylor was his name?
AUDIENCE: Bob Taylor.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Bob Taylor.
AUDIENCE: He was picking people
whose personalities meshed well
with the group, and
stuff like that.
And then Bennis
emphasizes so much
about how great
groups can really
affect people's family life.
It seems like they kind of
exclude a lot of people.
If you don't fit with
the leader of the group,
even if you could
have contributed,
you have a different
personality type,
you might not get picked
to be in a great group.
Or if you're a woman
who is expected
to see her children
once in a while,
how are you going to
hang in the great group?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Sometimes
fathers see their children
occasionally.
AUDIENCE: I know, but
I think there's still
a societal expectation of
women being somewhat more
present in their families--
whether that will
persist, who knows.
I don't know.
It makes me nervous when
we talk about perpetuating
great groups, when
they seem kind
of exclusionary, exclusive.
AUDIENCE: There's an amazing
point that you have brought up,
that I will touch on in a
second, the first one of which
is that I don't think that--
or rather, your
analysis, I think,
applies well to the
Tuxedo Park reading
that we did maybe two or
three classes ago about how--
what was his name,
Alfred Loomis?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Loomis.
AUDIENCE: Loomis was
hand-selecting people
that he liked to
work in his lab.
That doesn't seem
to me to be very far
from what he was doing in his
private lab, which is obviously
a point of concern, in
terms of including diversity
in your perspective--
[INAUDIBLE]
perspectives, not to say
anything of racial diversity,
and affirmative action right,
and including populations
that can be underrepresented
in science and technology.
But furthermore, also
while I was reading this,
I felt like it was
almost presupposed
that all of these people
were going to be white male.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So let's
go back to the beanbag slide.
AUDIENCE: There's a girl.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: There's two.
AUDIENCE: In the
reading, they only
mentioned one woman
explicitly, and that
was the woman who was the
graphic designer at Apple,
and so she didn't have
any technical capabilities
and didn't have much
of a role to play
within the
organizational structure.
And thus, her
influence was very low.
So I really call into question
precisely what Beth is saying,
but would almost say
that it's not something
that makes me nervous.
It's something I
find outrageous.
MAX: So I would say actually
to somewhat counter that--
definitely I agree,
women in STEM
fields-- that we definitely
need more representation.
But it's possible
that, at the time,
there was less of an
emphasis on STEM education,
which would mean--
AUDIENCE: Oh, no.
So I totally agree
with the reasons--
or rather, I understand the
reasons as to why it happened.
But as being these
scholars are thinking
about organizational
structure, they're
not adding in any
caveats about the roles
in which these social
factors have to play.
And furthermore, they're
not making recommendations
as to how they
could be resolved.
Because if they are
not the ones addressing
these holes within
organizational structure
and how people can--
people's perspectives can
be meaningfully included,
then you're just glossing
over that as an issue
and leaving it for
someone else to resolve.
And so that was my concern with
this reading, in particular.
I can have a concern writ large
with sexism in the workplace,
but I try to focus
my concerns generally
with the literature with
which we are engaging.
AUDIENCE: So you're saying
this was an omission
from [INAUDIBLE] writing?
AUDIENCE: Correct.
Yes, specifically.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARTIN: I would counter,
in terms of-- because it
is a question of our time.
I think that there will
be an organization that
is more prone to females
that does better [INAUDIBLE]
doing it or there's
an organization
that's all-female because of
the structure being different.
Because it's something that
I started seeing when I did
work as a diplomat in Mexico.
Their social structure
was much more extreme.
So if a daughter was
seen working with a man,
the parents would like, ugh.
So they started making special
groups just for these females
so they can move forward
and get an education.
And I think that's
a problem that
can be more prevalent outside
the US than in the US.
But also, if you
give a good answer
and have really good talent--
because these people are really
more competing for talent.
And you find a way of accessing
it and changing your structure.
Because it might be
that this structure
of always being very intense.
Being on location is a
problem women with children,
so maybe changing the
structure around--
Yahoo try to do this,
[INAUDIBLE] ability
to work from home or
choose specific days
so you can hang out
with your children.
Also because most-- more
organizations are going to try
to become--
they want this model.
I think there's going to be
companies that are going to be
very intense and then
mix vacation time,
because they know work life
balance [INAUDIBLE]---- well,
it's not working.
So you have to find
a way of mixing it.
So it's like, OK, you have this
problem, you have this project,
you've got a deadline, and then
you have two, three days off.
Because you need to
have a certain intensity
for a certain amount of time,
but that you can kind of relax.
And that's going to lead to
less turnover in employees.
Because that's a big issue.
If you have employees
that are working very hard
and they don't get a break--
if you have a cord be
too tight, it snaps,
and so you want to make some
loosening and tightening
to get a right cord.
AUDIENCE: I also
wonder how applicable
this is to the context
outside the West
and outside the United States.
In terms of work culture and
organizational structure,
I think a lot of other countries
culturally or just society
have different senses
of obligation to family
and community at large.
So I think that
this is definitely
a very Western, maybe
very US-centric approach
to how analyze great groups.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yes.
Sanam, I think that's
an important point.
This great group series
that we're doing really
does reflect an
American culture.
And how does that
great group theory
translate into other cultures?
I think that's a really an
important underlying question.
And as we said a
couple of weeks ago,
I am open to other great groups.
So when you all have
candidates that open up--
is the 1970s.
That's as far as we've gotten.
We've covered the 1940s
pretty well and '50s.
Now, we're at the '70s.
Not much has changed.
And I'm not sure much
changes in any of the groups
that we're going to
talk about today.
I think it starts to get
better in places like Genentech
and Craig Venter's operation.
And the problem is you've got
to find a technology that's
taken off so you can prove
that the group accomplished
something.
So if you all would
help me with this
and find examples that I
can include in the group,
it'll be--
MARTIN: [INAUDIBLE] is
capitalism and technology
so that's going to be a group--
it is going to be
pretty much white males.
If we redefined it as
the top working groups
in different fields--
so it can be like
music, like soul music.
How do they stretch themselves?
We might be able to
find [INAUDIBLE]----
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Yeah, you tried
to raise this last week, Martin.
MARTIN: Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I still
wanted technology though.
MARTIN: [INAUDIBLE] or maybe
you can go back in time
[INAUDIBLE] different countries.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
I don't know.
I think things are
starting to change.
We'll see.
MARTIN: We're also looking
at the popular ones.
So maybe we can look
at top technology
in like India, top technology
groups in other countries.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
AUDIENCE: I think we
already did Japan.
The thing that I
remember kicking myself
for not bringing up, when
you were talking about Japan
and how incredibly prolific
they were, and the--
their economic growth is
that they created effectively
a workplace culture that
relied on two factors--
one, devoting your
entire life to your job--
one job you choose.
You're with a company for
the rest of your time there.
And then two, that if
your entire self-worth
as an individual is tied to
your success within this company
or the success of the company
generally, then if you fail
or if the company fails, you
feel like you're effectively
threatened.
And what I mentioned
to Bill, and something
that you may know,
is that there's
an incredibly high suicide
rate amongst Japanese workers.
So what does that mean if the
culture that we are trying
to create here is
effectively trying
to emulate Japan's,
because we want
to achieve their level
of economic growth,
if it is that they have
reached the sort of peak human?
Is that what we
have to aspire to?
And what might be
some lessons for us
to learn from that
country, as a great group?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
OK, that's fair enough.
So Luyao, do you want to give
us a couple of closing thoughts
about the groups you looked at?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think
definitely these lessons
learned [INAUDIBLE] I'm
amazed, as a Chinese background
student, with this flat
structure of a lab.
That would never happen
in Chinese culture.
It is always hierarchical.
I think other things that's
been changing better in China
is the sense of female
scientists' position in China
has been actually leading in
all these other countries.
We have a larger number of
female scientists, I think--
we are highly ranked.
And there are
lessons to be learned
from different countries
and from across history.